on this episode I get to hang with one
of my favorite legendary chefs
you ask
ha
this is
ask Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 211 of
the askgaryvee show I'm very excited to
be here at Red Rooster in Harlem with
this wonderful wonderful human being
that I've known from for a long time
from afar growing up in the wine
business watching the food culture world
recently we've been able to spend some
time together I really personally
enjoyed that thank you I think we have a
lot of similarities I learn every time I
hang out with he's always something but
he's never the stuff that I thought it's
not like we discuss blind yes I actually
talk about all the life there is life
life exactly great once you tell me a
few that don't know who you are who you
are my name is chef Marcus Sampson I
have a restaurant here in Harlem and
called Red Rooster and I've really been
able to discover the world and discover
myself through food hard work but also
through the restaurant industry and I'm
still just as curious and love this
industry because essentially is about
people neighborhoods and community and
this restaurant Red Rooster has the best
uploads all that that's great and so why
don't you give because I know this a
little bit why don't you give everybody
you're gonna be humble but I want to
establish it and India will get into the
questions give a little give a little
bit of your not like from the beginning
but like from the beginning of your
restaurant career sure paint me a
picture so what's your first job in the
restaurant is string my first job was
like Monsieur F a dishwasher
yeah rightly making meatballs with my
grandmother okay and that's that's a
great start
yep right playing Top Chef at home
before there was even a talk against my
sister's yep how old are you at this
point
uh that's six seven and then I got 9 and
14 so I lost yep but the idea of making
[ __ ] matters yeah making what weaken
yeah making Herring pickling and you
know our big thing of pickling and lo
sweets have a hot summer house in a
basement where the preserved food was
because we were afraid of the Russians I
get it we were convinced that the
Russian becomes wet to store food just
in case or when they come so this is
like that's really where that making the
art of making something on my dad's side
everyone was officiating fishermen so I
had a real
from both side big aspirations big dream
got scholarships to go to Switzerland
France working some of the toughest
environment ever loved it
but really the breaking point to me was
after friends I went to Japan changed
everything because Japanese food at that
point wasn't no years it I would say
1991 ok wasn't even on the world map
outside Japan right sushi culture even
in New York or SF was non-existent
non-existent and for me to stand there
and just learn from these guys and you
don't even understand what they were
doing but knowing that they got it and I
don't an order from that excited you oh
my god and I had to be really listen and
just learn and learn and learn and it
changed my perspective on food it really
did what for somebody for some analysis
are people that are curious what what
would you say in a sentence changed well
first of all raw food right and then
your friends we have to cook with heavy
creams and sauce which I'd like to take
urate precision uh they're tight
yeah the commitment to trip their
tradition yes not looking outside right
France isn't the gold standard
no we it's about us here yep and that's
how we roll yes and no mom I wish I
didn't know was mama at that point but
that's Labor point between you know me
so sweet and salty she taught me a lot
but again bean blot in Europe at that
time with ambition not just to work in a
restaurant but to be the guy owned the
restaurant a French chef told me he was
he was really clear to me said listen
I'm gonna give you peace advice get out
get to the steaks I know you want to own
your business it's not happening it's
not happening and you could look at that
two ways like he was very rude he wasn't
he's sort of trying to help cut through
he was not help and it was game-changing
means that came to state you know it's
interesting we talk about this just a
little side note we'll get back to show
it's literally how I think about my
business shows and content it doesn't
taste so good when I'm like you're lazy
yeah but I'm just trying to help ya and
it really helped you how does that work
with the Millennials Millennials are
just like every other generation there's
unlimited lazy people at 50 and 60 yeah
I think the Millennials have a bad rap I
think it's old man and old women talk on
them that's
I really do I think there's tons of
Millennials that are hustlers yeah um I
do think they've lived in a great year
uh but I think Gen X did too I mean I
think I think every generation that gets
away from generations that fought in
wars is softer because they can't even
understand the alternative of all the
luxuries when you're complaining about
not being able to afford an iPhone
versus your grandfather running on a
beach and getting shot in the face and
dying that's a very big difference we
see it also athletes if you compare sort
of like my Monalisa generation since
this is just so in front of us versus
the generation of kortner athletes
athletes 30 40 50 years ago how to work
during the off-season yeah yeah you know
of course India let's get into this show
yes the show Jared Jared asks as digital
is evolving what could TV chefs be doing
to keep their audience engaged with the
community
I like that Marx way you know it's a
good opportunity you know as digital
valves TV chefs have up this is you've
watched this being in the food industry
you know I you know right now I'm saying
oh my god I'm taking selfies every day
when did entrepreneurs become rock stars
you probably seven to ten years ago
looked at you all your homies you guys
used to you had to be sitting around I
know how you guys roll kasama gays do
the same thing four o'clock in the
morning Spotted Pig somewhere wherever
you are and you're sitting there and
you're saying one day hell did we
because like this is what happened a
decade ago
I think it's progression that came from
two or three different ways right
first of all julian jacques pepin hodge
never said a those two separated em will
really be absolutely part of pop culture
Absalom Bobby really took it this right
I don't think the word team shots gonna
just gonna leave it's really about media
whatever you watch it on that's
essentially what what's going to matter
right
so the screen for us was also about
figuring out sometimes we do long-form
sometimes we do 15-second video sure I'm
sure in five years or 50 seconds video
is gonna be five seconds or or I'll be
honest with you what we're producing is
we're going 20-30 minutes I'm basically
producing a reality show a documentary
on a 2 to 3 time a week basis so there's
a I think we're gonna come good contents
good cause that people kind of find
Colin do you does it come natural to you
or I
like when I look at you from afar you're
such an operator you're such a chef
operator you're running businesses how
about the media side of things
has it come natural or is that been
something you know it's important but
it's not doesn't come that natural I'll
tell you it's a couple of things for me
being adopted kids in Sweden we were
constantly stared up nothing is not in a
bad way but we're always in the center
and right so I look at it almost as the
same scene it's like okay you have
something to say don't cry about it
you want people to come to this space
and make it sticky you've got to
communicate that and you've got a
communicated hard if you're going to cut
through the clutter this yes larger
space and we either want to have
customer or don't yes you want it we ask
for this engage yes got it
very good the I'll jump in real quick I
would say new platforms always offer the
best opportunities this is good advice
for everybody right now
he and I'm saying this out loud for him
and his team because I want him to he
should very much look at musically and
if he cooks behind music on musically he
could be the DJ Khaled of musically and
it could change his life I'm being that
Syrian we picked that I'm like what life
feels I feel is coming I feel what's
what's going on what's going on I'll
tell you what's going on I'll save you
time yes same day no that you say no to
a lot of things get your busyness and
nature and you them coming to you with
none Julius I'm on their side not on
their side but Marcus I mean that
serious if you were to make a commitment
for 30 days to make three videos a day
of cooking behind music on musically I
am convinced done done you have to I'm
America I'm gonna check in 70 days and
blow up your spot yes I'm gonna use this
clip yeah and then it's gonna [ __ ] you
Marcus as a video like so you understand
int and in line for that okay so for
everybody I'm starting to articulate
this d-roc this is gonna go somewhere
I've been saying it but I've never said
it direct beachfront property the first
people that bought at Malibu the first
people that bought in the Hamptons the
first people that bought a Manhattan the
first people that bought in DUMBO when
you buy up the real estate that becomes
the market first you get a better deal
dj khaled
if you try to execute now and snap [ __ ]
it's it's noisier Ashton on Twitter it
would
change this career musically whatever
else you want to take a look at every
time there's something new or a new way
to do things for example we are crushing
video on Facebook right now we're
committed to it I'm hiring more people
because right now it's important to
Facebook which means it's getting more
reach yeah I'm very focused on it so
either new platforms that are emerging
and snapchat is still that still got
that yeah so please did you
you live in many worlds yes you're an
immigrant yes you're entrepreneur yes
you're in jeongmi do new media but you
also have a lot of friends that are you
know much older than you but also you
know almost like mentors but they do
business with you how did they respond
to your sort of cultural success but my
thing has worked for me progressively
because at first base achill II have
started from out of my mind and
completely an idiot - he's been right
for so long he's probably it's
unbelievable how 70 year old tycoons and
other people that are winning now come
and look at me when I say any I feel
like in another five or seven years I'm
like okay listen here's what you do go
naked a hard wheel and make it a gift on
I said gift not Jeff and make it on
smoogle smoogle com that's one day old
and I feel like very established people
be like all right so so what's happening
and I'm sure you felt this in your
career with food as you build reputation
yeah and you know the good thing about
reputation and you've had been the
beneficiary of this as well it's earned
yeah like it like people don't want to
listen to me as a matter of fact a lot
of people that listen to me and give me
respect do it begrudgingly yeah because
I do it with a different kind of vibe
than they Blahniks you know it's very
dire and so and so I think what's
happening is just like at same time when
I listen to you honestly know I
appreciate very W very direct like no
it's not like really thought about how
correct that's interesting this time I
don't think I value a lot so that makes
sense makes me feel good
India stamping coin
what's the biggest change tech is
bringing to the restaurant industry
connectivity to the the biggest change
to tech to the restaurant its
connectivity with the consumer so the
editor used to be you know the guard
maybe was a couple of newspapers a
couple of magazines
listen that consumer out there that is
connected to that is now the most
important person this happened in the
wine business
it was Wine Spectator it was Robert
Parker period New York Times for you and
maybe a couple of other things Gary Vee
wasn't up there not yet I started a
process other and then it was technology
I rode the wave it wasn't me it was me
understanding what YouTube and Twitter
was going to be Instagram some my friend
you know Andre Mack yeah Andres my boy
like like I remember those conversations
early on in Harlem that's right I was
like Andre this is happening he's doing
a nice job and watching him on the gram
right now like I just knew that was
coming and and I don't know what's going
on in the restaurant world I feel it's
probably similar to what's going on the
wine world a big Wine Spectator and a
big wine advocates core still really
matters I'm sure the same way in New
York Times review matters but now there
are taste makers you know but the world
is not either/or it's both right it's
not right where there used to be one
option I mean all my friends I look at
Foursquare I look at pictures of the
food when we get to
like yeah yeah Tristan is a good friend
like one of the guys from the Foursquare
Justin walk he's the best yes I love
that dude as good guy
I love his talking about mode I I was an
investor in koala and remember she was a
competitor of Foursquare and I remember
being on a call with a bunch of the
investors in people on the team I'm like
this guy Tristan walkers a problem yeah
even I think that at the highest company
as it's meant as the highest judgment
I've you know I've I've been an enormous
fan of his for a long time and you know
he's get up you should have him on the
show he's get up it's a medal from
Queens here's the best I believe schools
but that's the hustle way best best
I'm from Daniel Daniel Daniel asks the
best way for a culinary virgin to step
up to the plate what's the best way for
a complete culinary virgin to step up to
the plate Wow
yeah I get it I mean really first of all
gags a friend that you really you know
love adore admire and cook with you
because once you do it by yourself and
you don't know anything about food it's
hard because it's a it's so many things
is arugula better than this letter so
I'll get you to LA right so if you cook
with somebody that you trust and you're
gonna have fun with and same time bring
some wine and you know stick to it for
30 days on the 17th day I'm gonna call
you if you're not sticking with her
should i man yeah
Marcus can I say I'm gonna go side
question a little question for me one of
the things that I've enjoyed in the food
scene obviously living in New York has
been amazing for this is when a new
thing pops up yeah when I mean a new
thing I actually mean an ingredient or a
spice or a thing
yeah like is there any vegetable or
fruit or spice that's emerging right now
in the scene I'm fascinated by that so
first of all there's very little things
in the food scene that are new I know
that because it really is a new
interpretation what happens is go back
to the France NER when we brought so
much from just Europe and France and
venture Italy there was still a lot of
opportunity so what we look at now is
new is very often from
not even Japan anymore maybe Korea but
also now a little bit for Peru it's
definitely a strong marker ooh Peru and
what do I mean what do they got going
out because you think about extension on
the sushi culture it's obviously Terra
dito seviche and the stuff that we hear
still don't know that much about yes and
then the last things that's going to
come even more is Africa so when I
brought the oldest spice plan in the
world to America you know bad urban air
which is an Old Spice plan I hope you
looked at me like that's not new we've
had it forever or if you think about
argan oil that come from Morocco argan
oil is mostly used in makeup right yes
all over yes but cooking wise it's a
pretty new oil here in the West to cook
with the middlee and you know so they
might imagine I mean people have been
cooking with it for 2,000 years
what about meats like from Africa like
well that do you think 20 30 50 years
was it cuts my crank you know because
the meats are pretty traditional right
but then the cuts that we're using my
change and also that is old-school right
like works when the chef's talking about
something's old-school somewhere always
exactly but we've haven't maybe focus on
that country that's right
I love that all right India next add you
CJ listen listen listen
we accessed can we just have a little
bit of corn bread with tomato tomato jam
we up get short and I'm not eating
really yes so until I have to get back
home to your house my characters okay
let's sound guess where do you see the
Kahn district oh all right that's it for
chose s where do you see the coffee
industry going in terms of gastronomy
and coffee shops
that's a good question the coffee
industry the coffee industry first of
all I mean it started from Ethiopia and
places like that in that region but now
I think you have 80 countries producing
coffee so that's like it's very very
very global right now right so I still
think we're just here in terms of
intense beans in terms of the coffee
Carmine's made the wine business in the
90s exactly so they're mixing I think
we'll see more coffee and wine bars
together a great coffee in the cocktails
the way you see fresh juices going in
with
this now you devil huh you know what's
so interesting I've been thinking of a
concept of a bar that is just 24/7 yeah
because and it goes from coffee to
juices to T to wine to post-game tell it
I'm like really I think there's a really
interesting model from a place that's
open 5:30 a.m. to 4:00 in the morning in
New York that is very hardcore
structured around four to six different
afternoon tea mmm right like coffee
juices afternoon tea wine but all the
things have what we're talking about
here it's they're having intense flavors
right because that coffee and that juice
is based on intensity
yes espresso with fresh juice yes next
to it will it's a ginger and orange so
people today want intense flavor we want
smaller shots of something we're really
intense so that can be done wet bar
something you just like it's just liquid
we thinkin names that I just want to
open it I'm a India last one Tommy Tommy
Tommy asks any suggestions on how to use
social media to promote a quality
imported olive oil Wow
I mean social media why wouldn't you use
it utilize it for any product right
first of all olive oil people love olive
oil already right so you want to tell a
little bit terroir where it's from and
then also how it's used best case
scenario but also maybe a surprise olive
oil as an ice cream or olive oil cake
something that is just a little bit
off-center I think social media would it
be perfect platform so you can cut
through I have a very good answer to
this I believe really I feel excited
about this influencers influencers
influencers ask ask ask I would go to
Instagram search hashtags olive oil but
then cheeses and breads and cakes and
ice creams uh and I would literally for
11 hours a day is your business you have
an imported olive oil because like what
are you doing like you know what are you
doing 7 p.m. 8 p.m. 9 p.m. 10 p.m. 11
p.m. 12 what are you doing you're doing
a lot of [ __ ] a lot of times I would
allocate 6-7 hours a day and I would
literally you search hashtags
you find somebody's account it's a sous
chef in a Kansas City restaurant that
has 813 followers but the Gmail accounts
theorem say look I'm importing
amazing Avila I'd like to send you a
bottle I'd like you to put a post a
picture of it on Instagram if you have
it and then you wait that person replies
it goes sure they've never had anybody
reach out to them and give them olive
oil for free and they're pumped or they
write back
yeah but I'm an influencer I get four
hundred dollars a photo and you're like
well that's not enough for eight hundred
dollars but it's just literally
literally
I actually believe that if you have a
product like an olive oil or any product
that influenced your marketing on
Instagram right now and then and then
unbelievably dirty get dirt under your
fingers grinding one by one Gmail Gmail
Gmail Gmail click on account finder
Gmail Gmail them Gmail get like eight
nine ten hours a day I'm up and then to
come up every [ __ ] day up here yes we
should talk about god I have so many
things none that yes
poor bastards are dead or dead and I
love this but the big part of this guy's
the big part of this is to ask can you
take this camera away and just Rick and
just direct the conversation right
because this is my uh uh uh it's easy to
pass on them I know a lot on that post
up your the bottle dirty thirty days
thirty days yes I'm you know ask so many
of you are just not asking you the fear
of rejection or the laziness of the
execution is stopping people from
winning happiness I think that is a very
very strong it is one of those two
things Marcus I'm telling you right now
if you actually have a product and you
actually spend ten hours a day and I
love when people are like ten hours back
I was running a very large wine retail
business and when Twitter came out I
went pot committed all-in and I was
spending ten hours a day
I built my entire brand from that
ecosystem
it wasn't mainstream media it wasn't
winning you know an award and having the
entire brass my words I'm not belittling
that's all that I'm not baloney I caught
it he's right he's right no but but but
I've never had you know I get it I'm
happy for you that was fun to watch and
I'm happy for everybody I'm but like
it's unbelievable what ten hours a day
of asking 815 Scheffel a day on
Instagram a hundred nine
laughs we'll take a photo with your
olive oil 39 moms that have a lot of
other moms that give it up we'll take a
photo with your olive oil and it's just
the work and the asking smart and it's
free like you masses are you building a
Trump you know I'm gonna be you I don't
I don't want to get into fights with any
judges uh this is actually really good
education free yeah
for life I love that question of the day
Marcus you get to ask the question of
the day you get to ask them any cushing
want there's a lot of entrepreneurs a
lot of business ppl it's also probably a
crowd that is probably that mainstream
foodie you can go anywhere on this I
want anything you want but actually want
to ask you because I want to don't ask
me ask them
we went hundreds of answers on my
facebook in YouTube snapped
we went from Twitter Instagram to
snapchat yes what's the next platform
that will have the same cup through over
the next three to five years answer my
friends you keep asking questions we'll
keep answering them
what do you think I think musically is
the first thing that's got a chance and
I don't think you can ever answer it
yeah because you have to react to it
instead of predicting it it's too hard
to prepare
somebody's building it right now you
just don't want else guys from from
because no you know what's so funny they
could be anywhere there give me two
girls right now in Kansas City they'll
probably end up in San Francisco because
that's where the VCS in a tech talent is
but you know snapchats in LA yeah
Pinterest started in Pennsylvania moved
to San Francisco Facebook started in
Boston yeah move to San Francisco so I'm
not sure I just have you have you
talking
how do you guys have you guys looked at
it and yeah cool and honestly spend one
hour googling musically read all the
articles get it down but and then reach
out to mainstream media like whatever
context you have they're dying to write
an article about it so like I already
see the headline like is Marcus the DJ
Khaled of musically and that alone
almost starts it being that oh thank you
you're welcome
sup guys hope you enjoyed the show
please do I get to link it up anywhere
is it like in here or is it down below
is it in print or is it in my video
it'll be a beatdown it's here down to my
left
like right here there's a button for
them to subscribe to my YouTube video
yeah it's a little buggy thing that's
right guys like this
that's right use that